[Music]
this is festival foodies where we go to
fairs across the country and try three
things a fan favorite a hidden gem and a
wacky snack let's dig in
[Music]
hi I'm AJ Anna and this is festival
foodies today we're at the Minnesota
State Fair I'm from Minnesota and let me
tell you this is a peak event of the
year for Minnesota I am so excited to be
here I made extra room in my stomach
good cuz you're gonna need it let's get
started let's go so the Minnesota State
Fair was started in 1854 so we've been
around for a hundred and sixty plus
years so we have more than 300 food
vendors serving up five hundred
different types of food 80 of which are
on a stick which is kind of a big deal
we have nearly 2 million people who come
to the Minnesota State Fair first up is
the fan-favorite the first ways I have
to take you is sweet Martha's cookies
this place is synonymous with the
Minnesota State Fair it is by far and
away the most popular vendor here
everywhere I turn I see these buckets of
cookies it's my turn let's go I actually
grew up about a mile away from the
fairgrounds and as a little girl wanted
to always have a stand at the Minnesota
State Fair flash forward to 40 years
later here we are on the average we sell
about 1 million cookies a day we can
make about 40,000 cookies in 12 minutes
52 tons of chocolate chip for the whole
fair so Minnesota has a large appetite
for cookies it's really become a great
staple of the Minnesota State Fair so
the first thing you notice when you're
handed a pocket of sweet Martha's
cookies is the sweet sugary snow that
walks in your nose and makes you so
hungry let's dive right in right now
yeah what are you waiting for
oh my gosh it's the perfect chocolate
chip 250 ratio down Saipan and they're
right out of the oven so the chocolate
literally melts in your mouth because
it's a little warm and gooey you know
with your first hand at the bucket
you're like how am I gonna finish that
but then you try the cookie you're like
how am I not gonna finish that I can eat
this bucket all day long
[Music]
sweet Martha's is the fan favorite
everyone knows about this place but I'm
gonna take you somewhere that not as
many people know about let's do it all
right next it's time for a hidden gem
these fries are keeping things fresh at
the fair if there's one thing I love
it's fresh food so let's dive in we have
the freshest fries in the country I
think we have locally grown potatoes
that were picked just days ago and we
put them straight from the the farm into
the peeler into the cutter and straight
to the people waiting for them so we
really think we make the best french
fries on the planet we try to do the
best job we can every single day so the
Minnesota State Fair is 12 days long and
in those 12 days we use 400,000 pounds
of potatoes we use about 3000 gallons of
oil and then we actually go through
about 25 to 30,000 pounds of ketchup so
the volume is huge I think the Minnesota
State Fair is just an incredible
tradition in our state okay Jay are you
ready to try the freshest french fries
east of the Mississippi I am so ready
crispy on the outside
fluffy on the inside I love these fries
because I'm all about freshness and you
see the potatoes going in being chopped
up they're coming straight out it's
french fries they're truly the freshest
french fries
[Applause]
those fries are fantastically fresh you
know what it's time for now what time is
it it's time for wacky snack whack it's
nap
let's do it last but not least our wacky
snack now you can only get these pickle
dogs at the Minnesota State Fair oh I
love pickles I cannot wait to see how
they change with the pastrami right
brother let's dig in we started the
pickle dog we've been at the fair
Minnesota State Fair for 29 years we
probably used thousands of pickles here
at the State Fair a days the pickle dog
we take pastrami bread cream cheese on
it
and wrap a pickle sphere around it we do
get a lot of repeat customers back at
the pickle dog stand they like the
pastrami I grew up in Minnesota my
husband grew up in Minnesota and loves
the Minnesota State Fair I've never had
anything like this before so I don't
really know where to expect right now me
neither but let's go for it all right if
you say so
whoa you've got the sweetness for the
cream cheese painted with like the
sourness of the pickle it's like your
favorite deli sandwich but wrapped up
like a burrito skip the carbs perfect
and buy it right here this is the most
unique thing we've eaten all day
definitely unique I could go for a
second me too
[Music]
being of the State Fair is bringing back
so many fond memories of when I was a
kid here okay AJ as a first-timer here
today out of everything we ate what was
your favorite I have to go with the
fries I love fresh foods and those fix
fries are so for us there's so crispy
they're so fluffy on the inside I just
couldn't stop eating I'm with you I
agree perfect mix up greasy salty potato
egg all right Ally I know you're an
experienced fair goer but what's your
favorite thing okay I have to say sweet
Martha's cookies they lived up to the
hype I know they're a fan favorite but
they really are delicious these cookies
are gooey and warm out of the oven so
crushed oh and you get a whole bucket of
them I don't blame you for picking
well that wraps it up for a time at the
Minnesota State Fair but we'll see it
the next one stay hungry
[Music]